c'est désormais bien connu les vaccins à
arn messagers files heures et modern a
ainsi que le vaccin ce tracé n'est qu'à
doivent être injectés à deux reprises
pour assurer une protection pleinement
efficace le délai entre les deux doses
et de 21 à 49 jours pour les vaccins à
arn messagers tandis qu'il est de 9 à 12
semaines pour le vaccin
astrazeneca mais l'injection d'une
troisième dose prend de plus en plus de
place dans les débats au sein de la
communauté scientifique notamment face à
l'émergence de nouveaux variants alors
l'injection d'une troisième dose est
elle indispensable
sommes-nous totalement protégé contre
les variants ou une dose de rappel sera
nécessaire d'ici cet été
des experts y répondre dans ce nouvel
épisode de factures que ce soit pour les
vaccins à arn messager ou le vaccin
astrazeneca la logique de deux doses est
équivalente
la première dose introduit l'antigène
visé dans l'organisme
tandis que la seconde renforce son
action et prolongé la durée de la
réponse immunitaire
si l'hypothèse d'une troisième dose est
autant discuter c'est tout simplement
qu'avec le temps la protection induite
par la primovaccination est voué à
diminuer c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire pour certains vaccins de
faire des doses de rappel c'est le cas
du vaccin dtp contre la diphtérie le
tétanos et la poliomyélite
mais aussi le vaccin contre la
coqueluche ou encore le vaccin contre la
grippe pour les personnes à risque
ainsi dans le cadre du cauvel 19
l'injection d'une troisième dose
présente plusieurs intérêts d'une part
renforcer la réponse immunitaire face
aux des russes et d'autres par contré
les variants pour heavy
une nouvelle vague épidémique on parle
d'une troisième dos pour améliorer la
réponse immunitaire
on va faire remonter manière très
importante le taux d'anticorps et pas
uniquement des antilles qu'aux contre la
souche initial donc c'est la meilleure
manière d'avoir une réponse immunitaire
j'étais là un peu à plat
en plus on sait que la diminution dans
le temps du taux de ces anticorps après
cette deuxième stimulation le système
immunitaire est beaucoup plus long
initialement l'arrivée depuis plusieurs
mois deux variantes du corps et 19 sur
le territoire vous fréquemment la
question de l'efficacité des vaccins
on va vers la mode chauffage
d'où les spots de vejle cloud faxing
cette troisième dose présenterait
l'avantagé de faire remonter le taux
d'anticorps limitant la circulation du
virus ainsi que l'émergence de nouveaux
variants toutefois c'est la forme que
prendrait cette troisième dose qui crée
un clivage au sein de la communauté
scientifique
si à l'image de l' oms ou des
laboratoires certains appellent à
utiliser logiquement les mêmes vaccins
d'autres plaident en faveur de vaccin
adapté à ces nouveaux variants ce que
l'on sait c'est que les vaccins actuels
ont l'air de fonctionner à peu près bien
sûr les variants qui ont circulé et
qu'on appelle maintenant alfa beta gamin
c'est à dire qu'ils sont venus des îles
britanniques d'afrique du sud et
d'amérique
il semble également que de premiers
résultats montrent que les vaccins
peut-être une efficacité diminue et
contre le variant origines indiennes
qu'on appelle delta et gamma ya
plusieurs fois farine d'origine indienne
on sait que cette efficacité diminue et
dont des tests de laboratoire ou n'a pas
encore de résultats d'efficacité en vie
réelle qui nous dise si oui ou non c'est
max insuffisances il faudra une
troisième dose
un vaccin spécifique il n'est pas sûr
sow va avoir des modifications très
important de des souches du sascoc deux
poumons soit obtenu deux mois il est
même une revaccination avec le vaccin
initiale sans pertinents mais on imagine
par exemple ça du tout que le virus de
la grippe donc seront vaccinés avec des
vaccins complètement différent tous les
ans à l'heure actuelle on n'est pas dans
ce cadre
si rien n'indique concrètement que le
gouvernement va mettre en place une
troisième dose de vaccination les pays
de l'union européenne se préparent
toutefois à ce scénario
notamment pour éviter les pénuries d'eau
livraison auquel ils ont dû faire face
en ce début d'année
énarque enclos de négociation vaio x
files ou fournis aux craintes à new york
tout cela est surveillé sont extrêmement
étroits il ya de premiers résultats qui
sont assez haut pour un jour qui montre
que peut-être ce ne sera pas la peine
mais rien n'est sûr pour l'instant tout
est prêt les doses sont prêtes les
nouveaux vaccins sont prêts soient des
vaccins identique soit des vaccins
contenant les 20 ayant faim tu qu'on cet
éventuel réinjection ratel lieu là non
plus pas encore de critères précis pour
me dire il est possible que cela se
fasse à l'automne et cela va
essentiellement des banques de
l'épidémie mondiale pour l'heure si
seules les personnes immunodéprimées
sont concernés par une troisième dose de
vaccin soit moins d'un pour cent de la
population
les résultats sont encourageants très
clairement la troisième dose permet de
remonter le taux d'anticorps aux
personnes immunodéprimées des
protecteurs par contre il existe une
petite frange de patients qui eux ont
des médicaments très puissamment immuno
suppresseurs donc qui bloque de façon
très puissante le système immunitaire
chez ceux là et bien là
la 3e 12 n'a pas été efficace mais c'est
une petite frange de la population
reste que si les recherches se
poursuivent
déterminer la durée exacte d'efficacité
des vaccins notamment face aux variants
plusieurs scénarios sont sur la table et
dans l'hypothèse d'une troisième dose
rien n'indique que celle ci sera
suffisante est une quatrième dose ne
sera pas nécessaire à son tour
[Musique]